Oscar Wilde
His wit was legendary.
His literary works showed signs of brilliance
and his lifestyle made him, for a time, among
the most celebrated artists of the age...
Yet his spectacular fall was unprecedented,
only equaled in modern times by the disaster
that was O.J. Simpson.
In this weekŐs Biographics, we delve into
the outrageous life of (self proclaimed) genius
Oscar Wilde.
Beginnings
Oscar Fingal OŐFlahertie Wills Wilde entered
the world on October 16th, 1854.
The flamboyance of his name was a portent
of things to come.
His parents were socially prominent Anglo-Irish
Protestants, each with eclectic interests,
a belief in national politics, and publishing
careers of their own.
OscarŐs father, William, was a renowned
physician specializing in the eye and ear.
He was a slight, unkempt figure with an ugly
beard and a roving eye.
But that did not stop him carrying on numerous
affairs throughout his marriage, and he fathered
several illegitimate children.
In contrast to her husband, OscarŐs mother,
Jane, was especially elegant and statuesque.
Almost six feet tall, she towered over her
husband.
She was a woman who Ôlonged to make a sensation,Ő
once stating that ÔI should like to rage
through life - this orthodox creeping is too
tame for me.Ő
And, well, you probably guessed that this
was an attitude that her son would quickly
embraceÉ
When Oscar, her second son, was eight months
old, Jane described him as Ôa great stout
creature who minds nothing but growing fat.Ő
Jane had wanted a girl and is said to have
dressed and treated Oscar as a daughter for
the first decade of his life.
At age nine, Oscar, along with his older brother
Willie, was sent to his first school - the
Portora Royal Boarding School, in Enniskillen,
far in the Protestant north of Ireland.
Oscar was younger than most of his peers.
At first, he was eclipsed by his older brother,
but by the time that Willie was set to leave
Portora, he had been superseded academically
by Oscar.
In fact, the younger Wilde was intellectually
far ahead of his classmates.
In 1889 he recalled . . .
ŇI was looked upon as a prodigy by my associates
because, quite frequently, I would, for a
wager, read a three-volume novel in half an
hour so closely as to be able to give an accurate
resume of the plot of the story; by one hourŐs
reading I was enabled to give a fair narrative
of the incidental scenes and the most pertinent
dialogue.Ó
Higher Education
In 1871, Wilde won a scholarship to study
Classics at Trinity College, Dublin.
He arrived there in 1873, aged 18.
There he was tutored and befriended by Reverend
John Pentland Mahaffy, Professor of Ancient
History.
Mahaffy inspired his pupil to be proficient
in Greek and, in 1875, he won the prestigious
Berkeley Gold Medal in Greek.
Three years later, in 1874, Oscar sailed to
England to take the examination for a Classics
scholarship at Oxford University.
While awaiting the results, he went to London
and was dazzled by his first taste of the
metropolis.
After that he headed off to another metropolisÉ
Paris.
It was there, with his mother and brother,
that he received news that he had won his
scholarship.
HeŐd not only won it, but heŐd achieved
the highest mark of the entire groupÉ
Oscar made the most of his time at Oxford.
It was during this time that he cultivated
his aesthetic sensibilities, filling his room
with lilies and spending vast portions of
his fatherŐs money upgrading the decor in
his room.
It was at this time that he famously said,
ÔI find it harder and harder every day to
live up to my blue china.Ő
Wilde was never a fan of sport, but he enjoyed
watching others play cricket and run.
He developed a reputation for his wit, proclaiming
that Ôthe only possible exercise is to talk,
not to walk.Ő
Still he was no pushover.
It is believed that once, while in his room,
four undergraduates pounced on him to beat
him up and smash his belongings.
Wilde is said to have kicked out the first
interloper, punched the second as he doubled
over, hurled the third through the air, and
carried the last back to his own room and
tossing him on the floor.
It was during his time at Oxford that Wilde
became a MasonÉ
He adopted the costume - velvet breeches,
tailcoat, white tie and silk hose.
But his extravagant lifestyle was dented in
April 1876 when his father died, leaving a
serious debt behind.
Oscar though, he still managed to find a way
to indulge himself with semester holidays
around Europe...
Just prior to graduation in 1878, he consoled
his mother, distraught with financial worry
that Ôwe have genius - that is something
attorneyŐs canŐt take away.Ő
Oscar emerged with a degree from Oxford, and
a clear vision of what was in store.
In a remarkably prophetic couple of sentences
he declared, ÔGod knows, I wonŐt be a
dried up Oxford don, anyhow.
I cannot live without desire, fear and pain
. . . self-poised, self centered and self
comforted.
IŐll be a poet, a writer, a dramatist.
Somehow, or other, IŐll be famous, and if
not famous, notorious.Ő
In December 1878, Wilde moved to London.
He shared a flat with Frank Miles, a fellow
Oxford graduate.
During this time, he was introduced to many
writers, artists and actors.
He soon gained a reputation for his wit, and
became a favored dinner guest, where he would
espouse his aesthetic values.
He applied for various fellowships and even
tried to become an inspector of schools.
Meanwhile he was working on his first play,
Vera, which was privately printed in 1880.
Vera was a story of noble socialism set in
19th Century Russia.
But, unfortunately for Wilde, the London And
New York producers who Wilde sent the play
to turned it down.
Literary Beginnings
In 1881, Oscar published sixty-one pieces
of writing under the title Poems.
An initial run of 750 copies sold out, with
two further printings being required.
Meanwhile, a play by the renowned team of
Gilbert and Sullivan was, indirectly making
Wilde famous.
It was called Patience and was a lampoon of
the aesthetic culture that Wilde epitomized.
The main character was clearly modeled on
him.
By June of 1881, WildeŐs status was such
that the Prince of Wales commented, ÔI do
not know Mr. Wilde, and not to know Mr. Wilde
is not to be known.Ő
Despite his ever growing reputation, Wilde
found himself in tough financial straits.
He was offered, and accepted, a series of
lecture tours around America to coincide with
the New York opening of Patience.
He set sail on Christmas Eve 1881 to instruct
the New World in ÔThe English Art of Renaissance.Ő
On arrival, he told a New York customs officer,
ÔI have nothing to declare but my genius.Ő
DonŐt try this today anyoneÉ
Well, the Americans were fascinated by him
and the original schedule would be extended
repeatedly in response to public demand.
It would last almost a year, and even extended
to Canada.
Financially, he did very well out of the lecture
tour.
He stayed in New York for two months after
the tourŐs end.
He then briefly returned to London in January
1883, before relocating to Paris, where he
immersed himself in artistic circles.
He now made himself over physically.
He had his flowing locks transformed into
a bowl haircut and took to wearing a black
overcoat...
This was in great contrast to the flamboyant
colors that he was known for.
In May, 1883, Wilde returned to London, apparently
motivated by his interest in a woman named
Constance Lloyd, the daughter of a prosperous
London lawyer.
For the last few years, despite his American
earnings, Oscar had had money worries.
The right marriage might solve them, while
also answering growing gossip about his sexual
character.
A year-long courtship followed, with the marriage
taking place on 29th May, 1884.
They honeymooned in Paris and then, thanks
to his new father-in-lawŐs money, occupied
a four-story house in London.
He then went ahead and had the place redecorated
at huge expense, which plunged the newlyweds
into immediate debt.
WildeŐs first child, Cyril, was born on
June 5th, 1885 with Vyvyan following on November
5th, 1886.
With his writing career going nowhere, he
agreed to a British lecture tour with topics
such as ÔThe Value of Art in Modern Life.Ő
Lecturing and other invitations kept him away
from the family home.
During his long absences he began to surround
himself with young men, writing unguardedly
of his infatuation with the beauty of the
male form.
He formed an especially close friendship with
a seventeen-year-old named Robbie RossÉ
Success & Scandal
During the late 1880Ős, while bringing in
money with occasional book reviews, Wilde
worked on his first novel, The Picture of
Dorian Gray.
When the book was published in a magazine
in 1890 it caused an immediate scandal.
The storyline involved a subtly eroticized
triangle of relationships between three men
and was condemned by many as being immoral.
Wilde had predicted such an outcome, having
written the following in the preface ŇThere
is no such thing as a moral or an immoral
book.
Books are well written or badly written.
That is all.Ó
It was around this time that Wilde was introduced
to a blond fair skinned undergraduate by the
name of Lord Alfred Douglas, but who was known
to his intimates as Bosie.
Oscar quickly became obsessed with the twenty-two-year
oldÉ
From this time on, Oscar saw Constance and
his children less often.
He did his writings from rented addresses
or hotels, usually with Bosie in tow....
BosieŐs father was the Marquis of Queensbury,
the man who developed the rules of professional
boxing.
He took an immediate and intense exception
to the relationship between his son and the
famous Wilde.
Apart from the homosexual aspect of their
relationship, Queensbury was enraged that
Wilde was distracting his son from his studies
at Oxford.
When Bosie quit his studies in May, 1893,
the Marquis became determined to bring down
Wilde.
It was around this time that Wilde finally
achieved success on the stage.
A Woman of No Importance opened on April 19th,
1893 to widespread acclaim.
During its long run, it brought him between
170 and 200 pounds per week.
His next play, the satire An Ideal Husband,
was also successful, providing the means for
Oscar and Bosie to travel widely and live
extravagantly.
The Marquis of Queensbury thought his sonŐs
failure to take his degree in Oxford was a
scandalous waste of time.
He placed the blame squarely at the feet of
Wilde, referring to the relationship as the
Ômost loathsome and disgustingŐ.
Queensbury began hounding the pair incessantly.
He threatened to disinherit Boise.
To this the son replied in a telegram, ÔWhat
a funny little man you are!Ő
Queensbury didnŐt like this one bit, and
on the 19th of June, Queensbury burst in on
Wilde at his Tithe Street address in London.
He had a bodyguard with him and proceeded
to threaten bodily harm unless the relationship
was immediately ended.
And what was Bosie reaction to all this?
Well, he wrote nonchalantly to his father,
ÔI write to inform you that I treat your
absurd threats with absolute indifference.Ő
The encounter though, it unsettled Wilde,
who got out of London for several months,
going on holiday with his family to Worthing.
This is where he worked on his latest play,
The Importance of Being Earnest.
But it wasnŐt long before Bosie, unable
to stay away, invited himself alongÉ
As you might imagine this caused a certain
degree of tension between Mr. and Mrs. Wilde.
Trials
The Importance of Being Earnest opened to
great applause on February 14th, 1895.
Two weeks later it was already a ÔwildŐ
successÉ
In true Oscar WIlde style is began basking
in the glow of this, Wilde called in at the
lavish Albemarle Club...
There he was handed a card from Queensbury
by a porter.
On this card was scrawled, ÔTo Oscar Wilde,
posing sodomite.Ő
At BosieŐs urging, Wilde went to Marlborough
Street police station to ask for a warrant
for QueensburyŐs arrest on grounds of libel.
The case came to trial on April 3rd.
Prosecuting Counsel, Edward Carson put on
the stand a sixteen-year-old Ôrent boyŐ
who claimed to have been paid for sex by Wilde.
Carson then went on to dissect WildeŐs published
works, revealing their supposed homosexual
undertones...
And how did WIlde react to this serious event?
Well, he chose to wield his celebrated wit
as his main defensive tool...
He was often funny, but the implicit superiority
in his position was also damaging.
In one exchange, when Carson asked whether
the affection and love that is portrayed in
The Picture of Dorian Gray might lead an ordinary
individual to believe it had a sodomitical
tendency, Oscar replied, ÔI have no knowledge
of the ordinary individual.Ő
Not exactly endearing himself to anyoneÉ
WildeŐs counsel, Edward Clarke, made serious
miscalculations that did his client no favors.
He went over letters that Queensberry had
sent to his son in an attempt to show how
crazed the father had become...
To the jury, though, QueensburyŐs volatility
was driven by a paternal regard for Bosie's
character.
As Carson put it, his client had one hope
alone, and that was simply saving his son.
On the third day of proceedings, with things
going not exactly brilliantly...
Wilde chose not to attend.
This was to prove the most damaging day yet,
with Carson announcing that he intended to
introduce a number of boys who would testify
to Ôshocking actsŐ performed by Oscar...
Without consulting with his client, WildŐs
lawyer, Clarke, offered to abandon the case.
The defense, however, insisted that the original
plea stand.
The judge agreed and compelled an acquittal
from the jury.
Queensbury was found not guilty of libel against
Wilde.
It had now been proven that his written accusation
of sodomy was not libelous.
Now this had another important consequenceÉ
It Wilde highly vulnerable to arrest for sodomy,
which was a crime in England at the time.
And, well this happenedÉ
At five in the evening of the day that the
libel case was decided, a summons was issued
for the arrest of Oscar Wilde.
The charge was Ôcommitting acts of gross
indecency.Ő
Hiding in the Cadogan Hotel, Oscar was urged
by Bosie and others to take a boat immediately
for FranceÉ
Even his wife told him to run.
However this just didnŐt sit right with
Wilde.
He was determined to stand his ground, declaring,
ÔI shall stay and do my sentence, whatever
it is.Ő
At 6:10 pm, two detectives arrived, and took
a semi-drunk Wilde to Bow Street station.
The arrest of Oscar Wilde caused an absolute
sensation.
Any friends that he still had quickly drifted
away.
Both of his currently running plays were cancelled
and his name very quickly became toxic.
Wilde was kept in a cell in Bow Street (then
in Holloway Prison).
Queensbury now administered the low blow of
forcing a bankruptcy sale of OscarŐs belongings,
helped by a long list of angry creditors.
By this time, Wilde was about Ł6000 in debt.
After making sure that Oscar had nothing of
any physical value left, Queensbury wrote
to a newspaper denying that he was capable
of any sympathy for Wilde.
He stated ÔI have helped to cut up and destroy
sharks.
I have no sympathy for them, but may have
felt sorry, and wished to put them out of
pain as fast as possible.Ő
The trial ran from the 26th to the 29th of
April.
It was extraordinarily explicit in its allusions
to sexual acts, many coming from the young
men who claimed to have been partakers.
Various Savoy Hotel employees testified that
they had seen boys in WildeŐs bed.
However, OscarŐs counsel was able to point
out contradictions in the testimonies, especially
those of the Ôrent boys.Ő
This all meant that the jury were unable to
reach a verdict.
But WIlde was not out of the woods, as an
almost immediate retrial began.
Between the two trials, he managed to secure
bail, though stiff conditions were imposed...
He tried to stay at a number of hotels, only
to be told at each that he was unwelcome.
He finally managed to find lodgings with his
brother Willie.
The second trial began on May 22nd at the
Old Bailey.
This time, after two hours of discussion,
the jury returned with a verdict of guilty.
The sentence?
Two years hard labor.
Confinement
Wilde was taken to Pentonville Prison.
The wooden bed in his cell had sheets and
rugs but no mattress.
A tin pot was provided for his toilet.
The prison clothes were not exactly his accustomed
style of dress...
Wilde was compelled to walk a treadmill senselessly
for six hours each day, and allowed to exercise
outdoors for one hour.
He was also forced to make postal bags.
For three whole months he had no outside contact,
and after that things were not much better,
with him only being allowed to write one letter.
The regime was brutal...Wilde recalling three
punishments authorized by law - hunger, insomnia
and illness.
In September 1895, he received a visit from
Constance who found the experience Ôawful,
more so than any conception of it could be.Ő
Constance reported that Wilde professed a
rejection of his former conduct, and begged
her forgiveness for his madness during the
last three years.
She decided to stand by her Ôweak rather
than wickedŐ spouse.
Still, she abandoned his name, referring to
herself as Constance Holland.
When Bosie heard about OscarŐs rejection
of his former lifestyle he was heartbroken.
He wrote, ÔI am not in prison but I think
I suffer as much as Oscar and in fact more.Ő
That was probably not the case thoughÉ
I mean, prison was pretty rough.
In October, he actually came down with dysentery.
On 21st November, he was transferred to Reading
Prison.
At Clapham Junction station, he was spat on
and ridiculed by the crowds.
Here though conditions were improved and his
duties were lighter.
He was released on May 19th, 1896.
Oscar was booked into the Hotel Sandwich in
Dieppe, Northern France, living off the generosity
of the few friends who had stood by him.
By now, Constance had decided on divorce and,
suffering herself with spinal paralysis, put
off any reunion.
Between June and July 1897 Oscar wrote his
last major work, The Ballad of Reading Goal.
The subject?
Well that would be underlining the need for
reform in BritainŐs prison and justice systemsÉ
Life in Dieppe was excruciatingly lonely for
Oscar.
Society at large shunned him and he spent
day after day alone and miserable.
Finally, his resolve collapsed and he wrote
to Bosie, inviting him to come and stay.
They reconciled on August 28th, with Wilde
bursting into tears at the sight of his Ôone
true love.Ő
When Constance heard of her husbandŐs behaviour
she wrote to him forbidding any return Ôto
your filthy, insane life.Ő
When he refused to give up Bosie, she cut
him off completely...
Once the initial passion subsided, it became
clear that both Wilde and Bosie were very
different than their pre-trial selves.
Bosie felt a duty to help Wide, but this was
no longer tied to love.
On December 3rd, Bosie left for Naples, and
did not return.
OscarŐs last two years - mostly in Paris
- where pitiful.
He drank, hired men, and begged.
Acquaintances were few.
Constance Holland sadly died age forty after
an operation on her back on April, 7th, 1898.
Then, in April, 1900 Wilde went with an acquaintance
named Harold Mellor to Rome, where he received
the PopeŐs blessing.
A month later he was in Paris and suffering
from ill-health, which he attributed to food
poisoning.
His skin was irritable, frequently coming
out in rashes.
By September, he was completely bedridden.
On October 10th, he was operated upon for
an ear infection.
The operation did not go well and he got worse.
Still he insisted on drinking absinthe and
champagne.
On November 25th a diagnosis of acute, inoperable
cerebral meningitis was reached.
From here on, Oscar drifted in and out of
consciousness and even sanity.
At half past five the following morning, a
death rattle began.
Minutes after his demise, his body actually
sort-of exploded, fluid pouring out of several
orifices.
Oscar Wilde died as he had lived - inappropriately,
outrageously and with scant reference to what
decorum demanded.